it's Jay Bilas with us here hi Jay why
am I so upset only because there's
nothing else that is this trivial but I
was I was equally as upset as you when I
saw the bracket and tried to change it
but to no avail
all right I I was that angry I don't
know if that was live last night but I'm
texting you that I was I was I wanted to
yell at somebody and so I I was yelling
at you so if you were busy working and I
interrupted you I apologize for being
unprofessional well that actually wasn't
live it was live on a Tuesday night or
it was supposed to be live and then Tom
Brady
I think hiccup tore something and it was
five hours of coverage five because
there was there was a hint he was going
to the Buccaneers so we had to tape it
we taped it and you know you know how
that goes dad when taped it as if it was
live and the taping as if it was live
took longer than if it was live yeah
I've been there before
okay so explain how this came about and
the number of players you know how did
you come up with that that number well
it came about like I assume the lack of
programming because of the corona virus
pandemic so I was told hey we're going
to do this show would you be available
you know basically from 6:00 to 9:00 on
Tuesday so of course I'm available
absolutely but I don't know how they
came up with it when i saw the bracket i
had said look you know the guys got to
be moved up here moved down what about
what about so-and-so how come this
players not on it and I didn't have any
any sane at I think they made a couple
of adjustments but I don't even know who
they is I just dealt with my producer on
that and it was a good idea I mean it's
a really neat thing and it's a good
discussion point a good argument but but
to me I don't know I don't want to you
know jump ahead but to me the whole
thing begins and ends with cream yes I
mean after after we're like over here
what are we talking about that Kareem
was the greatest player ever it's not
it's not a discussion point and we can
we can talk about the rest of them but
you know we know who's going to win
before we start
- Kareem yeah and rightfully so now if I
take away Lew Alcindor now we have an
interesting discussion I'm amazed that
you had I mean Jay Williams should know
better
he had Michael Jordan as the best
college player of all time yeah he
handled is a little bit differently I if
I understood him right he was talking
about if it were a one-on-one game which
I missed very much remember when CBS had
during half times they had one outlawed
in force competitions among the NBA
players so he had it as kind of some
one-on-one competition which I don't
have a cent a chance to talk beforehand
and I didn't get that but and I didn't
get some of the other stuff like yeah I
don't know if you remember what I did
but my thing was I didn't care where the
the seedings were and then I went
through the bracket said we'll wait a
minute like I this is a miss seating so
this guy's going to win I'm going to
move this one on and all that stuff and
mine was based on great who's that who's
the greater player and and so mine was
like cheryl miller was the greatest
women's player versus the second
greatest men's player i advanced cheryl
miller to the final it and it was cream
but just i went off great other people
voted differently or so you know for
championships versus if a Breanna
Stewart at 4 and I'm like well I think
of Kareem at played he would have got
four well that guy was he was the game
the in Greenberg made the point they
changed the rules for Kareem when he was
in college
you know transcended doesn't even LeBron
did not approach how good Kareem was as
far as being a high school player going
to college what he did college all that
stuff it was a different deal like he
was he was game-changing in every way
and above of everyone that had played I
mean and I I it stuns me man the people
don't seem to remember how great he was
and it's not it's not like I I'm fine
with let's argue about MJ versus cream
but it's MJ and Kirk only and then
everybody else will argue about a little
bit later but but it's it's those two
yeah I and I like in Cheryl Miller to
women's college basketball like I do
Martyna never told over two women's
tennis they were different they were
athletes in there and and Cheryl was you
know you watched Cheryl like I watched
the Women of Troy again I watched that
documentary twice now just because that
was a big deal at the time when they
knocked off Louisiana Tech and and
Cheryl scored a hundred points in a game
in high school she was she was a
difference maker if you want to put
Breanna Stewart as the greatest women's
college basketball player of all time I
have no problem with that you can't do
any better than she did you went four
titles and you're you know four times
the most outstanding player Diana
Taurasi I have no problem with that if
you want to put her in there as well but
the greatest player of all time is is
Lew Alcindor what drove me crazy is why
is Trey young in there he's not one of
the great college basketball players he
was there for one year
why is God I got Pete Maravich at 13 I
got Jerry West at 13 what is what's
going on here I don't know I don't know
whether it was it was frankly because it
was a television show and I'm just
speculating because I am talking to
anybody about this there are other more
important things that I'm told you are
too but my guess is and it is just a
guess is is that there were more younger
people involved in older people and and
they wanted they wanted a cross-section
where you did have younger players
representatives I didn't think Kevin
Durant should identify a fee one one
firm attack nine and and the only fit
look the only thing I would say about
nervous like I'm with everybody that
Maravich should not have been 13
whatever he was he should have been way
higher but Maravich never played an NC
double-a tournament yeah bad team though
I mean he was the only guy on his team
and in the you know the tournament
wasn't as big as it everybody makes the
tournament now I get it
I'm not I'm not I'm not saying he
shouldn't have been he shouldn't be
revered as one of the greatest of all
time but but I don't want to go too far
in the other direction either because
there are other guys like Elgin Baylor
should have been in Fadden yeah Elgin
Baylor didn't any teammates either
and and it's not like an Oscar Robertson
played with a whole bunch of superstars
you know played with good players I'm
not trying to cast aspersions on anybody
but it but other players were able to
get their teams but four more wins and
and Maravich didn't their their teams
didn't win not only Ben make the
tournament they didn't win at a high
level he was a great player he was no
questioned one of the greatest ever I'm
not arguing that but the idea that he
should have been up with Kareem and all
the others no no no I I her personal
championship series like some people are
parsing out saying okay well this guy
won this many championships he only won
this many okay Mariners didn't even play
in the tournament and everybody say we
should be up here I'm like look I'm not
arguing he shouldn't be but I'm like
let's have we can't talk out of both
sides of our mouths at all this I would
take Jay Williams out of this six spot
and you know put Pete Maravich there I
would take Jay out of the entire thing
after he picked Michael Jordan is the
best college basketball player of all
time I just slapped the floor that's
what I just did Jay I just slapped the
floor the problem that Jay had was he
was a sixth seed he ran into another
miss seeded player David Robinson and
David Robinson as you remember took navy
to the Elite Eight and were it not for
the opposing center here at ETSU they
could have got all the way yeah that's a
great point you didn't you didn't fight
on that one no no I'm not
I agree with David Robinson when you
were saying how he took a you know he
took navy to the Elite Eight I mean
that's pretty pretty amazing pretty
amazing and the opposing center he ran
into I mean you know and you shut him
down
exactly and later is in the conversation
as well I have no problem with that but
and I just like whatever all right I
know we let me tell you the lightener
went late I was I was a grad assistant
one later was playing maybe the greatest
competitor I've ever seen I mean
unbelievable
the guy was an unbelievable athlete he
could do everything and it's
he has equally and accomplished careers
maybe drown a Stewart if you want to
make sort of that argument yeah but he
like what would you do who is a better
player between Laettner and Danny
Manning that was a tough one for me just
better player I'm not talking about how
many rings list of accomplishment and
ease was damn close that was a hard one
like the one eighth matchup in the
second round you're gone I'm not sure
who's the better player Danny Manning
had less to work with and that was one
of the great tournament runs in history
with Danny and the miracles and what
they did in Kansas City you know it just
did late and I would take career three
over 3,000 points like you know he had a
ridiculous at the top of every list and
that's where the big 12 when they they
you know these big 12 records they
talked about that doesn't include the
big eight like so all the guys like Trey
Young's records and all that stuff that
doesn't include anything that happened
like Wayman Tisdale or Danny Manning or
all those guys that play in the big
eight that doesn't even count something
12 they didn't even bring those records
with it's crazy I got to go back - yes
pni I'm announcing now that I'm going
back to ESPN so I got to set some stuff
straight up there I'll do it Jay the two
of us can you imagine how what a
wonderful rest but that would be to have
us go in and argue about something as
trivial as this well I'm you be mr.
inside I'd be mr. outside - oh yeah well
that was my nickname in high school I
was mr. outside that was just your
social nickname no no I didn't go I
didn't go outside my social life but I
did when I was taking jumpers I was mr.
outside just letting you know I thought
you're talking about being like the boy
in the plastic bubble special relevance
now Jane yes I remember I thought you
were on my side here that was John
Travolta wasn't it
John Travolta and the song was written
by Paul Williams
yeah alright go back to doing whatever
you were doing and thanks for joining us
yeah I'm watching better call Saul I'm
now getting through the first season
it's fantastic by the way yeah it is
it's it's well done Thank You Jay all
right brother that's Jay Bilas